are you dare enter this house
you
you dare enter this house you bad
[ __ ] uncle Joey February 27
2017 swinging dick and telling people to
suck my dick you understand me the
clouds are out it's gonna rain but in my
world it's a beautiful [ __ ] day
to be alive because as long as I'm alive
I'm making the [ __ ] world beautiful
for one person me everybody else to suck
my dick [ __ ] you and the ask is it huh
huh the envelope wasn't jimmy kimmel
funny
he said funny Trump joke what is [ __ ]
wrong with America what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you people get your [ __ ] they
give us a [ __ ] about the wrong envelope
around those fake [ __ ] people fake
[ __ ] people I live here I see those
people I run from those [ __ ]
with their [ __ ] fake glasses no oh my
god that's so witty get the [ __ ] out of
here it's uncle Joey [ __ ] and this
world is real you understand this ain't
no reality show they say no TV show this
is the world the life you understand me
[ __ ] get missing eyes and [ __ ]
but that's why I'm here to help you out
and let you know [ __ ] all that [ __ ]
it's your world [ __ ] you don't have
to [ __ ] placate them [ __ ]
the more you think about those [ __ ]
[ __ ] the more you give them life
that's the problem I wake up this my go
on Facebook and be happy too Oh Denzel
Strait sat there with a straight face
and everybody was so funny now it's a
men hanging out with boys that's what
that's like
denzel's are those old [ __ ] that
you understand me sitting around with
those [ __ ] Momo's oh let me say
something witty so people could tap me
in the back about Trump get the [ __ ] out
of here get the [ __ ] back home smoking
reefer like a [ __ ] Savage
it's Monday [ __ ] grab your [ __ ]
salute the flag let these [ __ ]
know you got no time to [ __ ] around
today you don't want to hear about their
stupid [ __ ] stories and their giggles
and how they was sick oh my god the
gluten who gives a [ __ ] there's a [ __ ] a
protein shake a good [ __ ] you wash your
[ __ ] you salute the flag
and you're either like a [ __ ] sabot
you understand me enough with the
chitty-chat a Joey let's smoke this
[ __ ] number blue container we
got a red container and we got a black
to the hey and that's how we're [ __ ]
going deep they write your goals like
the universe know what you're gonna do
the power where the pen is the most
important thing in the [ __ ] world you
understand we don't believe the [ __ ]
light listen you know what makes me
[ __ ] a savage it's nothing oh he's a
funny comic a [ __ ] ain't [ __ ] with the
talent was getting him [ __ ]
that was the talent was getting here
from where how was that that's the
talent putting your head down listen I
don't know how the talent is getting out
of that [ __ ] mess putting your head
down telling these [ __ ] you
ain't gonna listen to them with their
stupidity and [ __ ] going for it you
understand me I went through I took a
chance and I [ __ ] went for know the
way you gotta break a few way he's gonna
break a few hearts but you don't give a
[ __ ] you know why cause you ain't got
that type of time God put you on this
planet for a limited amount of time you
want to be worried about what people
think who gives a [ __ ] I don't give a
[ __ ] what under these [ __ ]
think because at the end of the day when
I go to the supermarket I'm the one
they're standing the [ __ ] wallet you
understand me and smoke some reefer I'm
gonna but I'm ready for [ __ ] Monday
and if you're not waking up on a Monday
fired up right in the face go shoot your
[ __ ] self today's the day when you
say your market and enforce it you let
these [ __ ] know what's going on
me you call him at 9:00 they're picking
up the phone like oh my god I'm still
worried about the envelope who gives a
[ __ ] I'm talking about life [ __ ]
life and that's what's crack-a-lackin'
that's most of more easily
tremendous had a great time in
Minneapolis I brought the weed that
killed Prince for sold-out shows I love
you [ __ ] with all my heart
thank you very much tonight we got the
church at 7:00 p.m. and don't forget
tickets went on sale today for the
Borgata July 29th Atlantic City let's go
down and [ __ ] rip that [ __ ] place
apart and beside that it's your lucky
day [ __ ] you're gonna get up
you're gonna write you go you're gonna
wash your [ __ ] and you're gonna go out
there and set your [ __ ] marker and
enforce it like Tony in 84 maybe if
you're now gonna do that
go back to bed don't waste nobody's time
if you're not gonna be under 50% today
on a Monday call in sick go back to bed
no waste of your time don't waste my
time don't waste the savages around your
[ __ ] time you understand me today's
your lucky [ __ ] day God gave you
another [ __ ] chance to go out then
stick your dick in some of these [ __ ]
mouth do it you [ __ ] around make you
find a job
a problem Mexican to find a [ __ ] job
you should be ashamed of yourself [ __ ]
it's all about you to the people it's
all about you it's not about the movies
[ __ ] about that I'd still be mugging
people hanging out with [ __ ] dudes
couches funny joke get the [ __ ] out of
here
put your blinders down write down your
goals and go for it if you want it it's
[ __ ] there that prison counselor told
me Joey if I had something you wanted
you take it that's right you know what
that means I don't give a [ __ ] and
neither should you
because at the end of the day nobody
gives a [ __ ] about you guys go for it go
for it you're gonna sit there [ __ ]
around get yourself a job at night to
cover your [ __ ] little bills to all
your friends to suck your dick whatever
your dream is go free you want to paint
pictures of [ __ ] and think you could
sell them at the farmers market go for
it guess what you'll do it I was a
criminal Jack stone criminal and result
I drop your [ __ ] purse dog I don't
give a [ __ ] but here I am you know why
cuz I wanted to change that life I
didn't want to be a piece of [ __ ] no
more that was the most important I just
wanted to do something with my life
I didn't want to be rich I didn't wanna
have [ __ ] fancy cars I mean your
friends your heart and what the [ __ ] you
do for the people around you net huh
that was a witty thing you said about
trouble it's it's amazing how much you
care shut the [ __ ] up
I want a pat on the back like I want
[ __ ] a [ __ ] to suck my dick get the
[ __ ] out here
I'll get something shout out the Puerto
Rican Nelsons are still being them and
that's it and that's that it's Monday
February 27 another month goes by just a
week ago you were a jingle bells jingle
bound look at [ __ ] March 1st on
[ __ ] Wednesday what are you gonna do
it you still sitting there to chant your
quarters for your first ball what have
you been doing I don't know what the
[ __ ] I've been doing but today I got a
few meetings I'm gonna jujitsu I got a
podcast at 7 o'clock I'm willing your
deep tonight that's all that [ __ ]
matters
so listen today I want you to think
about one thing how you could be this
much better today that much better
that's why you subdue a suit this much
better maybe today I will hit somebody
in the head maybe I'm gonna steal this
and here we are [ __ ]
all right don't give up don't ever give
up
and don't let these guys dictate your
life flop them it's on your [ __ ]
terms
I'm not some County New Jersey home of
the famous Frank Sinatra he did it his
way
I'm doing it my way and you're gonna do
it your way I'll see you [ __ ]
tonight seven o'clock be there or be
square
uncle Joey don't forget Atlanta city
July 29 tickets going on sale Borgata
and i'll see you by the [ __ ] in two
weeks in Baltimore Magoo bees that's how
I'm wrong with my main man John Rallo I
want to give some shoutouts later Bobby
crystal tommy east of my favorite
[ __ ] zoo in the world lisa at my
favorite [ __ ] Jew in the world i'm
killed for that little [ __ ] you
understand me
you got a Cuban teamed up with a Jew are
you kidding me I love you [ __ ]
have a great day stay black and I'm
sorry I got emotional this morning I
just want you guys don't believe that
I'm the hype is you you're the hype
everything else is background music stay
black